lawmakers are considering a bill to
address what President Trump called a
top priority in his State of the Union
speech lowering prescription drug prices
the proposed creates act would target
what critics call our legal but
questionable tactics that drug companies
used to delay the introduction of
cheaper generic medications the FDA
Commissioner has called the tactics
quote shenanigans and quote unfair and
exploitative tactic practices Anna
Werner has been looking into this Anna
good morning what have you found
good morning John well this is a
situation where critics say that some
drug companies who want to hold on to
their exclusive sales of a brand-name
drug and their profits are playing games
to stave off generic competitors leaving
patients out in the cold so that's it
that's it it's the drug that's keeping
Pam Holt alive keeping her multiple
myeloma blood cancer at bay
it's called Revlimid and her copay runs
six hundred forty dollars a month I
don't know how anyone can afford that I
really don't
but Holt can't get a generic not because
other companies aren't trying to make
one but because critics say Revlimid is
one of a number of drugs for which
companies are using unfair tactics to
stifle generic competition this does not
help consumers they're paying more money
than they should be paying Rutgers law
professor Michael carrier studies what
he calls the games drug companies played
to protect their profits those games
take many forms in one form of Rand
company will pay a generic to delay
entering the market in another form it
will switch from one version of a drug
to another just trivially different just
to keep generics off the market they
call it lifecycle management
I call it anti-competitive conduct often
he says the games involve patents the
government protection that gives
companies the exclusive right to sell
their drug for 20 years but drug makers
have found ways to extend those
protections much longer take the
rheumatoid arthritis drug Humira talk to
your rheumatologist about Humera
that one drug last year generated 18
billion dollars for manufacturer add V
but its original patent was expiring in
2016 so to protect it
carrier says ad V built what's called a
patent thicket of more than 100
additional patents it uses that patent
thicket to keep any other biosimilar off
the market and when there are so many
patents on any particular drug it's easy
to find somewhere you can claim
infringement another tactic he says his
product topic where a company will make
minor changes to their drug like
switching from a capsule to a tablet or
changing the dosage every time there's a
change like this the generic has to go
back to the drawing board has to
redesign the product get FDA approval it
can't be substituted at the pharmacy
counter because it's a little bit
different and so that's what product
hopping is all about and Pam Holt's drug
Revlimid it's in a special group of high
risk drugs to make a generic version a
competitor has to be able to get samples
from original manufacturer Celgene but
generics manufacturer milan is suing
Celgene saying it won't provide the
samples and so has directly blocked
patient access to generic Revlimid and
prevented savings for patients and I'm
just learning that now so that is just
devastating to me devastating because
you know sick people should not have to
increase the profits of these huge drug
corporations at some point there needs
to be understanding that people should
be able to have the drugs that they need
to survive
Celgene had no comment about my --lens
lawsuit but in court filings called it
pointless the company also sent us a
brochure saying it's willing to make
Revlimid and other drugs available to
generic manufacturers that it
consistently offers and has sold samples
for what's called bioequivalence testing
so what do other drug companies have to
say let's look at the facts
Laurie Riley with the industry's
lobbying group Pharma told us the system
is working
90% of all medicines are generic over a
thousand new ones approved just last
year the highest of anywhere in the
world and over a hundred billion dollars
worth of new medicines going off patent
five years I think our system by and
large has worked tremendously well
you're basically saying that the games
are not happening I'm basically saying
that if to the extent there are issues
that there are multiple opportunities
and venues to address those
she says companies invest billions to
bring new medicines to market and need
patents to protect those investments and
to innovate our companies enter into
with a great intent of trying to make
their medicines more productive more
useful for patients and society always
with these I believe so yes without
exception well I certainly don't look at
every single patent a company gets but I
believe our companies act with very good
intent yes but Pam Holt says she's
decided to act to by joining the group
patients for affordable drugs using the
time she has left to fight drug
companies make you angry yes and it's
just so very irritating and so very
heartbreaking but there's so little
being done to help us AbbVie did not
comment on Humira Celgene says a generic
version of Revlimid will be coming out
in 2022 Pam Holt may not live that long
her doctors say at best she may have 10
years left now the company does offer a
reduced payment program but as a retired
educator Pam Holt makes too much to
qualify although not enough to avoid
going more than $7000 into debt because
of the drug it's on her credit card now
I love that Pam Holt is taking up the
cause I hope in this case doctors are
wrong and that it's longer than 10 years
she says whatever is speaking out she
says they've turned her into an activist
John you can see that thank you Anna